pardon monsieur faitgaben qui va à la
chasse garde sa place la commissaire
analytique blanchit le ministre
pierre-feugervin pour sa participation à
une partie de chasse au faisan vous vous
rappelez cet événement privé pendant
l'exclusif pour des riches gens
d'affaires où on se déguise en chasseur
d'époque où les faisans sont lâchés pour
ensuite être rapidement abattu par les
chasseurs tout ça sur une île privée sur
invitation seulement évidemment la
question était de savoir c'est le
ministre s'était placé en situation de
conflit d'intérêt en acceptant
l'invitation de Jean d'affaires qui
peuvent avoir des liens des contrats
avec l'État ou en côtoyant des gens qui
ont des liens ou des contrats avec
l'État voici la réponse de la
commissaire l'éthique dans son rapport
qui a été publié ce matin la frontière
entre la sphère personnelle et la sphère
professionnelle n'ayant pas été franchi
en l'espèce le ministre n'était pas dans
l'exercice de sa charge ainsi il n'a pu
se placer dans une situation où son
intérêt personnel pouvait être influencé
son indépendance de jugement donc elle
le blanchit mais mais mais mais elle
ajoute le ministre m'indique qu'il
comprendre par une nouvelle partie de
chasse il convient alors de formuler une
mise en garde à tous les parlementaires
dont Monsieur fitzguen il est nécessaire
et utile de rappeler que l'apparence de
conflits d'intérêt peut être tout aussi
dommageable qu'un conflit d'intérêt
avéré lorsqu'il est question de
maintenir la confiance des citoyens et
des citoyens donc non il n'y a pas de
problème avec la chasse au faisan il n'y
a pas eu de conflits d'intérêt mais pour
faire attention à l'apparence de
conflits d'intérêt réaction de
Pierrefitte gibben d'accord c'est cool
ok un mot sa réaction mais regardez ses
yeux
sont commentaires
quoi que ce soit dans votre façon de
procéder la prochaine fois que vous
allez
est-ce que vous allez changer quoi que
ce soit dans votre façon de procéder la
prochaine fois aucunement et il tourne
les talons et il sort il n'a pas la
suite rajouter qu'il y a une ligne entre
sa vie personnelle et sa vie
professionnelle ce que relève en effet
la commissaire analytique est-ce que
Jean-François vous êtes du même avis que
la commissaire il n'y avait pas de
problème avec cette chasse au faisan
il y avait pas de problème de fond il y
a un problème de perception et moi je
suis toujours d'accord pour faire une
différence entre le fond et la
perception et on ne peut pas se
gouverner constamment sur la perception
il faut aller au fond je comprends que
lorsque une perception négative il faut
il faut se poser la question est-ce que
c'est vrai qu'il y a un bruit d'éthique
et regarder la loi regarder les fesses
que fait la commissaire avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de délicatesse et je pense que
la raison et donc lorsque la perception
est contredite par les faits il faut
lutter contre la perception alors
évidemment pour soit je l'avais dit ici
je veux dire comme c'est un habitué de
ses chasses au faisant et il y a
personne qui l'a impressionné là et
lorsque il va souper avec ces gens-là
dans des grands salons de résidence de
westmart rien ne dit qu'il discute pas
aussi de dossier d'affaires et pourtant
on ne fait pas
[Musique]
ben c'est c'est extraordinaire il est
complètement blanchi mais aussi ça dit
il existe une marge de manœuvre pour
avoir une vie privée même si tu es avec
avec tes amis ce qu'on dit jamais que
disons un ministre qui vient du milieu
communautaire qui va à des souper
spaghettis avec ses amis du milieu
communautaire ils peuvent discuter entre
eux du fait qu'il y a pas assez de
budget gouvernemental pour les groupes
communautaires puis ça ça arrive jamais
au comité au Comité d'études puis mais
c'est le même principe finalement alors
moi je suis content d'avoir quand même
une ouverture de la commissaire qui est
une ouverture de gros bon sens si il y a
pas de s'il y a pas de smokingen il y a
pas de donne s'il y a de la fumée il
faut trouver si elle pistolet si on voit
pas le pistolet la fumée ne suffit pas
pour condamner quelqu'un alors bah tant
mieux tant mieux pour le jurisprudence
sur l'éthique tant mieux pour faire
Gabin puis lui compris que
l'avertissement c'est quand on dit tu
avais le droit de le faire vous avez le
droit de le faire entre autres parce que
tu l'as déjà fait mais j'aimerais mieux
que tu leur fasses pas il dit je vais
leur faire comme ça
est-ce que la planète est ce qu'il
fallait faire la plaine Michel parce que
Monsieur faitgabenzi attention au jeu de
mots les libéraux étaient à la chasse
aux sorcières plutôt qu'à la chasse au
faisant en portant plein contre
pierrefitte-gabin il y a quand même une
une qualité comme Jean-François le dit
au rapport de la commissaire qui qui
fait la part des choses entre la vie
privée d'un politicien et sa vie
professionnelle
tu es sûr que dans le jeu politique
faire la plainte ça va quasiment de soi
à noter
quand tu vois comme le fonctionnement
c'était
une cible extrêmement facile parce que
cette chasse là on frappé l'image là
parce qu'on pourrait se poser la
question c'est quoi la différence entre
cette chasse puis par exemple le tournoi
de golf le plus un des plus gros
tournois de golf au Québec et celui de
la fondation de Sainte Justine ou les
mêmes gens d'affaires se retrouvent et
là c'est les costumes et les faisons moi
je pense que ça a frappé de l'imaginaire
énormément l'île privée les hélicoptères
en fait c'est les riches et célèbres
c'est ça qui a vraiment probablement
choqué je dois dire que le rapport de la
commissaire et est quand même très
détaillé elle démonte qu'elle a fait une
enquête assez exhaustive par ailleurs
elle a interviewé beaucoup de gens qui
étaient présents donc pas uniquement le
ministre et meuf fouiller les
antécédents et tout ça mais elle dit une
chose dans son rapport vers la fin quand
elle dit oui c'est un activité privée
mais je préviens tous les élus qui
serait sage de développer des mesures de
prévention là où je reste sur mon
appétit c'est qu'elle n'a pas élaboré
qu'elle pourrait être ces mesures de
prévention
mais c'est un document public donc ça
aurait été intéressant que nous disent
un peu plus sur ces mesures de
prévention comme par exemple
exiger la liste d'invités puis est-ce
qu'il y en a qui ont des dossiers actifs
mais qui sont représentés au registre
des lobbysse et que et que le ministre
est un peu plus d'informations d'une
certaine façon est-ce que des
négociations en cours est-ce que si
est-ce que ça je ne sais trop mais
disons que elle lui laisse une belle
grande porte ouverte quand elle lui dit
ben soyez juste un peu plus
prudent la prochaine fois ça j'avoue que
elle pourrait très certainement aller un
peu plus loin à cet égard voici ce que
François Legault le patron monsieur
fatigue pense de ce rapport
cette accusation là des libéraux on a le
droit on a le droit sur ces temps libre
d'aller à la chasse moi j'aime pas ça la
mijoter
au tennis Françoise boucher de la tête
parce que je trouve pas que c'était la
déclaration la plus brillante de
François Legault parce que de rejeter du
revers de la main qui soit blanchi c'est
du Gabin c'est parfait d'ailleurs il me
semble qu'il devrait être souriant
aujourd'hui j'espérais tellement un
sourire de sa part puis de un
remerciement la commissaire d'avoir vu
la réalité puis d'avoir compris le
concept etc puis de peut-être envoyer
une petite pointe je pense c'est le
Journal de Montréal qui avait sorti ça
fait tout un plat s'entraîner tout ça et
et par contre la plainte dans des plaies
à François Legault elle s'y est attardée
quand même un bon quand même interviewé
de la haute gamme alors et le prix du
temps de prendre cette plainte là au
sérieux donc d'entendre mon premier
ministre et je dis mon premier ministre
parce qu'il est le premier ministre de
tous les Québécois et québécois
un petit peu ridiculiser la plainte sur
ça m'acha le petit peu faire sa blague
sur bon la chasse au faisan puis qui
aimerait bien avoir une photo je pense
que il rejoint un peu le propos de tout
le monde on aimerait savoir une photo
ouais on aurait aimé avoir une photo
pour voir de quoi exactement
mais dans ce cas là dans les mesures que
moi c'est pas clair dans cette décision
là parce que je suis d'accord avec
Jean-François c'est le fun qu'on puisse
faire la part des choses nos politiciens
là ils ont le droit une vie privée ils
ont le droit de continuer de faire ce
qu'il faisait avant mais il y a aussi
toute Laura de leur responsabilité qui
vient avec alors comment peux-tu
t'assurer j'imagine que au prix des
moyens la dernière fois ils ont tout dit
on n'a pas parlé d'affaires on
se concentrer sur les faisans les
costumes etc l'endroit et c'est tout est
convaincu bravo on pense à autre chose
mais sachez qu'il veut y retourner parce
qu'il nous le dit très clairement qu'il
retournerait mais peut-être qu'il
faudrait qu'il soit que il signe chacun
une vite qu'on on jure qu'on ne parle
pas d'affaires
tout enregistre madame mignonne
invitez la commissaire à peut-être
participé à la pour montrer comment ça
se déroule puis qu'a comprenne un peu
mais tout ça pour dire que monsieur fait
du Gabin il y avait l'occasion c'est sa
journée il y aurait dû avoir un pierre
faiscegobain l'air heureux des fois dans
vie quelle perte de yeux
va se retrouver dans les lits des
ministres pour s'assurer que tout est la
forme oh non quand même pas
Dimitri
parfait je suis content de savoir que
des limites au moins écoutez la question
que je me pose est-ce que Pierre
fitzgerbin allait à la chasse de faisan
avant de rentrer en politique et la
réponse est oui oui c'était son style de
vie pierre on veut tuer un ministre
Jean-François l'avait dit l'année passée
je me souviens je vous étiez
Jean-François est-ce qu'on veut ministre
l'économie qui ne provient pas du
secteur des affaires est-ce qu'on veut
un ministre de l'économie qui ne connaît
pas les gens du milieu d'affaires c'est
son monde il a probablement faisait un
million deux millions par année et là je
retrouve avec 100000 par année
heureusement qu'il va avoir une
augmentation de 30 %
et encore une fois et encore une fois
c'est le sixième oui exact plus que 2
millions c'est le sixième rapport
plainte par les parties d'opposition sur
pierre Fitz gibbin le sixième sixième
enquête 6e rapport 6e fois que la
commissaire alexique blanchit pierre
fait dubing donc
trois manquements mais un seul a été
approuvé ou sanctionné par l'Assemblée
nationale
ok merci pour la correction donc à
partir de maintenant on s'attend à ce
que pire fils Gabin et ses amis prennent
leur canne de pêche se retrouvent ok au
vieux port du Montréal pour aller à la
pêche tout le monde peut les voir il y a
pas de déguisement c'est la chasse au
faisant comme disait Michel et c'est
l'extravagance de l'activité qui fait en
sorte que aujourd'hui on parle d'un
rapport sur un ministre qui a été
blanchi
Jean-François un dernier mot sur la
question de la perception et de la
réalité il y a une citation de Johnny
Kennedy que j'ai toujours adoré il a dit
il y a pas de fumée sans machine à faire
de la fumée
c'est très bon en effet
petite note de bas de page parce qu'on
sera probablement jamais invité à ce
genre d'événement la Commission en
éthique décrit comment ça se passe ça
commence par un déjeuner à l'extérieur
de l'île ensuite les convives viennent
soit en hélicoptère soit en bateau privé
puis il y a 4 battus de nos quatre
sessions de chasse au faisant qui dure
environ une demi-heure chacune vers 14h
il y a un petit cocktail 14h15 on mange
les faisans Romains les faisant qu'on a
abattu les convives peuvent repartir
avec des faisans dans le code piafitte
Gabin il était pas reparti avec un
faisan selon ce que je comprends et s'il
y a des restes ils sont donnés à des
œuvres de charité voilà
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI